So I'll be talking my favorite number at the moment, which is the number 2025.
It's, just, it's 45 squared.
So it's a square number.
Don't get me wrong,
big fan, love square numbers, but there are loads of square numbers and none of them become
my favorite number.
This one,
because of a very personal reason and
the reason I absolutely love it is that
in the year
2025 I will turn
45.
And so for a brief moment I will turn
the exact square root of the
then-current year.
What a birthday party that's going to be.
It's gotta go off and
it's very rare. So very few people get
this. It happens to me because I was born in
the year 1980.
And so if you were born in 1980 and you
age 45 years, that's going to occur in the year
2025, which is 45 squared.
And so I get to be the age n
in year n squared and that is absolutely brilliant.
And if you look around the room,
or as you go about your life, look at all the masses of people out there,
none of them will get to experience this
undiluted mathematical birthday joy.
Unless, like me, they were born in 1980. It's just me and my fellow nineteen-eighters
to get to enjoy this because if you were
born any other year,
people who are currently alive, what, okay, people born in 1979
are all, like, oh but we will still be 45
at the beginning of the year and then will turn 46.
No. What are you celebrating? The end of it working? Right?
You want the birthday in the year. So all the people this previously happened to,
it's happened before,
they're all dead.
So back in 1892,
people who then aged 44 years
in the year... What's that going to be... I mean,
be sure I get this right,
1936.
That 1936 equals
44, yeah that's right, squared.
And so 1936 is quite the year, but no one is still around from the year 1892.
And it's not going to happen again until the year 2070.
As of 2070 those people when they turn 46,
which will occur in the year 2116, which is 46 squared.
[off camera] You thought about what you gonna do in your birthday?
Oh my goodness I don't know.
I've still got a few year, I got a decade of planning to go.
And it will be square themed.
All the food will be square shaped.
And not cubes, not cuboids.
People are thinking square cake. No.
It is the infinitely thin slices of square cake.
Although there are a few other people, who,
not alive at the moment, this is the only one,
who will get to be, in the future, at the very least, a root.
A nice whole root of the then-current year.
And it's, no, I mean, no one alive now,
you don't get,
no one else will be the cube root or any other power,
but there are a few coming up in the near future.
So if you wanna time when you're going to reproduce,
so that your future generations have the best chance,
if you carry on with the squaring one,
you get another year in 2162,
which is the next one,
that's when 47 gives you 2209, which is 47 squared.
But frankly that is a, I mean, that's a bit of a wait.
Before then, in the year 2046,
which is not too bad, we're talking your children's children, so, your grandkids.
You'll be around to see this one.
When they turn 2, that will be the year 2048,
which is 2 to the power of 11.
And so they will very briefly be the 11th root.
And as a bigger point though,
powers of 2, amazing numbers,
we haven't had a power of 2 since the 1024.
It's been over a millennia since the last...
ever millennium?
Eh, it's been over one of them.
Since the last time time we'll have a power of 2,
the next one is not for another two thousand years, have we?
4096 is the next time we get one of these.
So, just as a year, what a time to be alive.
Oh, my goodness.
Forget Halley's Commit.
Forget, you know, transit of Venus.
This you gotta wait thousands of years for when it happens.
So, come on, 2048 is gonna go off.
I messed around with all the other
possible powers to various years when that happens,
and they're all so infrequent.
They're so few,
but then I stumbled across the year,
and, this, I don't know that this is
as amazing as I think it is,
the year 2184.
And let's be honest, it's a way off.
I mean, we've got a lot to go in between here and there.
And we're talking how many generations?
I mean, that's, distant relatives will be around.
We'll be a long forgotten thing.
Maybe YouTube will still be around as some kind of archive or reference.
Maybe you'll watch this in a history class right now in the year 2184.
[off camera] How do you feel about people watching...
Oh, hello from the past!
And this this is how we use to live.
Here, I mean, these are, we used to use dead trees to store information.
Although, maybe, all of anything digital will be destroyed,
and they'll have no idea about YouTube but they'll still have these books.
We don't know.
But anyway, in the year 2184.
I'm talking directly to those of you in 2184 now,what a year.
But anyone being born in your year,
or if you were born in 2184,
you will at two different occasions in your lifetime be the exactly root of the then-current year.
And this just blew my mind when I  notice this.
So if you were born in 2184,
and you wait a little while, and you age at, we'll do 3 first,
if you age three years, so you're still very young,
you're probably unaware of what's going on around you,
that will then be the year 2187,
and 2187 equals 3 to the power of 7.
And so you will be, when you're 3,
you will be the seventh root of the then-current year.
But then, born in exactly the same year,
later on in your life when you turn 13,
so at least you're forming permanent memories,
that will be the year 2197,
and that equals thirteen cubed.
And so you will then be the cube root of the then-current year.
At the very least, it's been great talking to people from the distant 22nd century.
Hope you're having a great time in the future.
So here is the thing I'm talking about over here and, oh, here we have a clock.
We used to use this to tell the time when we physically rotated objects
to point at a kinda Runes that we had arranged in a circle.
And  these are cables.
We used to send information down these using electrons.
So we would send very specific electron along.
And, oh, this is a switch.
We have to physically hit things to change our environment and so we had to push the...
Oh this was an early...
We use this as sustenance.
So this is a basic food that you can both use and attach things to vertical surfaces.